new questions around the deadly shooting
of a black teenager outside Dallas
fifteen year old Jordan Edwards was shot
and killed by an officer with the Bulge
Springs Police Department Saturday after
a house party hundreds gathered last
night to remember the high school
freshman honor student who loved
football
Omar Villafranca is at the Bulge Springs
Police Department with the police chief
questions whether protocol was followed
home our good morning good morning to
Ball Springs police officers were
responding to a teenage house party with
underage drinking when they heard
gunshots
jordan edwards was leading that party
with four other teens when police tried
to stop them
what happened next left a 15 year old
dead and a community wondering what went
wrong I'm saying after reviewing the
video that I don't believe they did it
met her core values vault Springs police
chief Jonathan Hebert addressed the
public after reviewing body camera
footage of the shooting that killed 15
year old jordan edwards a police officer
shot the passenger side window of a car
carrying Edwards his brother and three
others as they left a party on Saturday
night according to the Dallas County
Medical Examiner Edwards died from a
rifle wound to the head on Monday Hebert
corrected earlier reports that the car
backed up aggressively toward the police
in fact according to the video that I
viewed the vehicle was moving forward as
the officer is approached
now that the chief has said that that
car was not moving backwards
aggressively what needs to happen to
that officer that officer needs to be
arrested they have no reasonable
explanation for the use of force
Lee Merritt is representing the Edwards
family he says no one in the car was
cited for drinking any weapons in the
car they did search the car for weapons
none were discovered the kids don't have
any history with weapons you know no gun
ownership no run-ins with law
enforcement before Merritt says Jordan
was a freshman at mesquite High School a
kid in love with life who had just
played his first year of football
Jackson Turner was his teammate it just
encouraged me all the time we were just
an encouraging personal he'll just like
the room but with that smile I'd just go
straight across his face
ball Springs police say the officer who
shot Edwards has been with the
department for six years and is now on
leave that body cam footage has not been
released to the public
Gale thank you very much Omar that
investigation continues